that happened in the finals that's just
wrong
here comes irving drives on thompson
irving spins
puts up the shot it's good kyrie irving
with 3.4 remaining
and the warriors call timeout
irving does it again to the warriors
the lob game that's so effective between
him james
hart great dish underneath capela drops
it in plus a foul
this is where capela
[Applause]
the bulls with a chance to win here on
christmas day grows left
throws in the lane throws good
derek rose and the bulls come back to
take
a one-point lead tony parker here he
comes to the top
parker at the top on
[Music]
wade looking for the return to lebron
off the window
they should just stop the game right now
and let everyone watch the replay
i've never seen that offhand
no off the window i've seen but never
with the off hand
[Music]
[Applause]
defense gets his hand right there loose
ball and we know nobody's going to be
able to affect that
[Applause]
and utah gets the ball seven
blocks
[Music]
[Applause]
john wall with an incredible hang and
score
wow that happened in the finals that's
just wrong
here comes irving drives on thompson
irving spins
puts up the shot it's good
[Applause]
irving does it again to the warriors
[Applause]
in transition wade finds james
grab that put it under your christmas
tree
oh my goodness what up it's your boy
adam lefkow do you like that content i
know you like that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report